two stories that dominated the headlines
this week focused on race and how we
talk about it the ongoing blackface
scandal in Virginia and the confession
by actor Liam Neeson that he at one
point in his life wanted to kill a black
man sometimes there's a disconnect
between what's offensive and why a
filmmaker from Buffalo New York has been
trying to create an honest and open
dialogue about race through his
documentary titled the blackness project
the name of which came in response to
another documentary on race Jericka
Duncan joins us for more on this Jericka
good morning good morning the
documentary discusses everything from
policing black communities to slavery
and even systemic racism the purpose of
the film is to encourage people to talk
about race related issues that can at
times be uncomfortable where we gather
to talk politics sports and yeah even
the blackness project doesn't shy away
from controversy black people get killed
by white men but going on to the end of
the time it seemed like Kapernick take
attorney is not just a piss-up to the
NFL and I mean it makes even gonna stand
against this country the documentary
filmed in Buffalo New York sets out to
explore what some black people think it
means to be black in America today the
opinions are very a teach my son that he
will always have to work ten times
harder every time I come into police
contact is always a problem of course I
hate that victimhood is taught in black
culture like victimhood who was this
documentary made for the documentary is
made for everyone 37 year old director
and filmmaker kori Green says he got the
idea for the blackness project after
watching the whiteness project featured
on CBS this morning back in 2014 21
Caucasians from Buffalo New York talked
very candidly about their race we're
gonna talk about black and in general
very beautiful people so when you smile
and you say hello that's not an
invitation to follow me
never knew certain white people felt the
way they felt so as I'm watching the
interviews it also educated me and I
said okay in order to really elevate
this conversation and take it to another
level I have to do a project where
people our respondents green interviewed
more than 30 African Americans from ages
18 to 70 including award-winning
Broadway actor Stephen Henderson
I was probably born colored and when I
went to school at an elementary school I
was probably a Negro Henderson who lives
in Buffalo has appeared in films like
Steven Spielberg's Lincoln you I was
born a free man nobody beat me except I
beat them right back and Denzel
Washington's fences long as you got your
complaint filed they can't fire you
that's what one in white fella tell me
he said he wanted to be a part of the
documentary to help facilitate a healing
we really do have an open wound in this
country events happen every week
unfortunately every day that exposes
that wound to infection healing is a is
a must we we have to make that effort
you being born in 1949 and when you look
back over in your life do you think
America is more divided today than we
were saved 20 30 40 years ago I saw
school integration so there was a divide
that was a really in line that you could
see there is a divide today but it's not
nearly as right in your face in the
documentary green and producer Pete
Johnson traveled to Utah to visit
ancestry.com headquarters to learn about
where they came from what they found
they say was surprising really a life
changing experience it helped me look at
life differently if someone was to look
at me from the exterior and say oh he's
an African American of finding my
ancestry I'm just a zero pain there's a
lot of people when I was first running
for mayor the city's first
african-american in current mayor Byron
Brown is also featured in the film at
one point he reflects on the time a
white man called him a racial slur
during his 2005 election campaign one of
the people at the event
said I never voted for an n IG ger
before but I'm gonna vote for you since
last year Green has held over a dozen
screenings in Buffalo we are one of the
most segregated cities in America
followed by a diverse panel of community
leaders who discuss the film no topic is
off the table
there's no black people in my church
where are they why don't they come I'm
wondering what do you think the
challenges are specifically for young
women and girls of color when you watch
the white is project and you watch the
black this project you can see this very
clearly and that the whiteness project
is clearly very unsophisticated do you
feel like people are ever too quick to
call out behavior as oh you're just
being racist absolutely everything is
not race related so you know if you
didn't do something right and you know
someone corrects it doesn't mean it's
the color of your skin the screening
show how talking honestly about race can
be liberating Green says it's
therapeutic for him and his audiences
all our screen has been predominately
white is that encouraging it's I can't
even tell you what it does for me it it
gets me emotional because here are
people maybe they don't understand my
story or any other story but the fact
that they want to understand says so
much we're going in the right direction
filmmaker Cory green and producer Pete
Johnson plan to screen this film again
this spring and you know they really
said the most impactful moments for them
were people walking away with an
understanding that they didn't have
before and I think that's what makes it
different - we can talk about having a
conversation but they were very
intentional about how they put this
documentary together and then they're
having these screenings where they're
opening it opening it up for dialogue
what's so interesting that that the
audiences are predominantly white that
is that says something right there I'm
curious quickly you said you spoke with
the quarry about Liam Neeson right
especially with that being in the news
and I just asked him knowing that this
piece was gonna air this weekend what
are your thoughts and he said you know I
don't agree with how he did this and and
what he said
but that's something he's also learned
through making this documentary and
having these screenings that you have to
be open to hearing people's rights and
as hard as it might be to hear this is
how we get to a better place
that's a society with this documentary
also what a great story Jericka thanks
to Rico